this episode of trash taste was filmed
in front of a live studio audience
which all stand for the game of national
anthem real quick
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to another episode of the
trash taste podcast I'm your host Joey
for today
and joining me as always is gone and
Connor and dreamhack Melbourne as well
what's up guys
it is good to be back in Australia
honestly I like it like this is our
second time in Australia right yeah and
the first time I came to Australia I was
like okay instantly Vibe with the
culture the people here I want to come
back and uh it's been like how many
months since we went to smash uh yeah
almost almost a year yeah almost a year
but that was Sydney right that doesn't
count that doesn't
well Melvin Melvin's better right guys
where can I can I get a bunch of hands
if you're local here in Melbourne
yeah did anyone fly in from Sydney for
this
[Applause]
I saw one hand right there you're in the
wrong place man I'm so sorry I I feel
like you know that Meme of the guy
standing in the corner of a club and
he's like they don't know I'm from
Sydney as well
no but I must say like I think you know
I have some family here now who have
like moved to Melbourne and stuff so
I've had like a lot more of an
opportunity to actually come to
Melbourne and I gotta say yeah Melbourne
you guys [__] rock like
wait are you saying you're betraying
your home City right now Joey I mean I
think I betrayed them when I moved to
Japan right that was a betrayal in and
of itself but yeah yeah what would your
dad think if he uh if he told him that
well it's funny you say that because
before I was born both my parents
actually lived in Melbourne I think they
lived in docklands so um yeah yeah I
know
so uh so my parents have been like
trying to figure out I think I think
their plan is like oh you know now the
kids are out of the house and like once
I retire I'm gonna be like I'll see you
Sydney I'm [__] going back to
Melbourne so yeah So eventually you
might see my mom and dad around here
would you be wild say hi guys I I feel
like I feel like my dad has just become
like a character in trash
yeah he's one of the most Aussie blokes
I've ever met in my life I want to hang
out with him again man I want to hang
out with you yeah I'm excited to see him
again but uh it's funny uh I remember
God saying the first time gone Connor
came to to Australia in Sydney
um you know there was a bit of
Australian patriotism
you know just being like okay you know
some of my best friends are in my home
country I kind of want to know what they
feel about Australia right so I remember
I said to them I was like how did you
guys like Sydney how did you guys like
Australia and I think gone put it best
uh in a in a rare display of British
optimism
he said uh it's like you know
the only complaint that I have is that I
have nothing to complain about
and then you were like it's like it's
like uh you said it's something along
the lines of like Australia's like uh
the UK except everyone's happy yeah yeah
hey man you're the ones that brought us
here yeah exactly it wasn't supposed to
be this way
why do we have why like the outside
right now when it's raining I was like
wow this is great weather in the UK
so we were doing the trash taste Cafe
earlier today did any of you guys go
yeah so I remember like the one number
one thing that people ask me when uh it
started raining was that oh you must be
cold right now right and I'm like no I'm
at home right now this is great
um but yeah the the first thing that I
noticed about Australia when I came here
uh I had just had the instant
realization of oh this is what British
people could be like if we had good
weather
I'm like you guys are like England and
the UK except you were just like taken
to the next level you guys are actually
happy no it was what was I remember at
Smash in Sydney
um it was like the first day and it was
like you know I kind of overcast like
there was some clouds in the sky but you
know still good weather you know nice
and sunny and uh and I remember God was
taught you were talking like a fan at
the con and I I overheard the fan being
like Oh yeah you know I know it's your
first time in Sydney blah blah blah but
uh yeah you know apologies for the [__]
weather
and you just like looked at him like
this is [__] weather what are you
talking about I like how a podcast has
become so the weather yeah right that's
what we talk about I was uh because I
had no idea what we're going to talk
about today I was in the when we were in
our room earlier I was like Googling
like things about Australia but it's
gonna be something fun to talk about
sure um and I googled the happiest
cities in Australia what do you guys
think number one was
see that's what I thought for some
reason Yahoo news said Canberra
[Applause]
which is the biggest cap I've ever heard
in my life I feel like the like the
three people there that's not a good
enough sample size right like that's
that's unfair I now that you say that I
really want to take these boys to
Canberra just just what's there
nothing yeah nothing yeah it's is there
anyone from Canberra here right now
[Music]
the only resident of Canberra right
there the only reason that City exists
is because Melbourne and Sydney couldn't
put their dicks away right like that was
like oh yeah yeah later okay fine fine
we'll make a whole new city
it's like it's barely a city dude it's
literally like all we have is like what
do we have in camera it's like the the
Parliament House uh which is like not
interesting in the slightest uh we have
that who cares about that we have like a
we have like a giant porn Factory there
for some reason
do you guys know about this
apparently in the ACT it's the only
state in Australia where it's legal to
film porn
yeah all the guys are like why am I not
living in Canberra right now
but like so yeah I remember like the
first time I drove through Canberra uh
because we were going somewhere I forgot
where we were not Canberra thank god
um we drove past it and I was like oh
it's my first time in Canberra like this
is sick you know I've always wanted to
see what it was like because I'd only
heard about it it's like it's the
capital city of Australia I went there
and it's like
oh my God the level of depression I felt
just like driving through this city was
insane and then there was this giant
like massive like five or six story just
completely pitch black building and and
I was like Dad what's that and he was
like that's the porn house son
the what the water house the porn house
oh the porn house okay that's the porn
house son and I'm like Dad I'm 10. I
don't know what that is so don't worry
you'll find out soon enough
and uh yeah that's my only impression of
Canberra but do you think it's uh better
than Perth because we know a few people
from Perth yes and everyone the only
thing I know about Perth is everyone
tries to get out of Perth as soon as
possible I don't know if that's true or
not I mean do you think it's true or
how many people from Perth
wow you traveled half the [__] world
to get here then
well because like okay I've personally
never been to Perth so I I can only
speculate right right but it is true
that I know about three or four people
all YouTubers by the way uh who won
Kevin and Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin pinken
our boy who were born and raised in
Perth who just coincidentally none of
them live in Perth anymore
so I'm like well I mean that but then
again it's like I feel Australians have
this tendency to travel like we we love
traveling for some reason why is that
what because you're in the middle of
them yeah you're in the middle of
nowhere so I guess that's true yeah I
guess the closest country to us is Papua
New Guinea and like who the [__] wants
to go to Papua New Guinea unless someone
in this audience is from Papua New
Guinea okay you talk [__] you can talk
[__] all right yeah uh yeah so
I don't know it's like what what are
like the Australian Hot Holiday uh
holiday Parts because because you guys
have to travel at least like [__] at
least six seven hours to like the
nearest place surely right yeah where'd
you guys normally go like Bali is pretty
common right yeah like so we have this
thing in Australia called schoolies
um yeah that's that's World fast and
PTSD for some of you uh so it's cool
okay so schoolies is this thing where uh
at the end of graduation basically it's
like a a graduation party of sorts
um and uh you know kids put in their own
money to go travel you know go bloody
basically it's like is it like a gap
yeah no no no not a gap year so so it's
basically just like maybe a week at most
they go out and it's basically just like
the last hooray of like yeah we
graduated from high school everyone's
like at least 18 now so we can all
legally drink so let's just go get
[__] up in some country and for some
reason Bali is like the go-to place why
does why does everything got to be like
e in Australia everything has to end
with something like wait what do you
mean like schooly or chewy or like
there's gonna be more examples right
everything just doesn't sound real here
well no no I I feel other than skooly
and chewy most things end with an o
That's who yeah you know like uh [__]
Servo uh smoker uh [__]
Pavo I haven't heard that word in a
while
it's just like it's like a Simpsons
language sometimes you guys you guys got
to come home and learning and using some
of this words because it there's a
reason why I still use it to this day
because it's just so convenient
it is it really is like you know I mean
it does roll off the tongue yeah like
one thing I never understood is that
yeah a lot of your slang words end in
O's yeah uh and then for your currency
you have Australian dollars right yeah
why do you not call it the dollar that
just that just that just seems like it
would fare well I don't know like it's
because it's actually called the dollar
redo
um
so uh yeah I mean you know we've told
that story in trash days of how I fooled
meleen into legitimately thinking the
Australian dollar was called the dollar
either can I yeah can I take a moment to
just like I I was I was buying a coffee
and they gave me the change yeah and
this [__] 50p
if I threw this up in the air a crater
would form when it came down what the
[__] is this
this must have cost like a hundred
dollars worth of metal to me what the
[__] is there a reason why it's like
it's funny you say that because like
until you pointed that out I it's I was
like oh yeah that is a big [__] coin
it just like you know you know come from
the UK we have coins that look really
like extravagant like this feels so
medieval thank you
like especially like the pounds like the
Shilling after the dollar yeah it does
yeah the two dollars it feels like
something like I'm like yes here you go
peasants take it
I have one gold piece in 150 bludgeon
piece
here you go povos yeah because you were
one of the first country to introduce uh
contactless payment right yeah yeah like
after seeing your 50p coin I understand
why you needed it yeah yeah there's a
reason why no one carries coins anymore
shut up Counter-Strike
this is more important
talking about the weight of a 50 cent
coin yeah
yeah but like then again it's like I
don't know Australia I feel has this
like tendency to be the first to invent
or come up with things but not be the
best at it like what like what uh like
Wi-Fi
oh where you guys invented [__]
invented Wi-Fi did you know this yeah we
invested is this an I made it the [__]
up moment no there is no way this is
true it's it's from the University of
Adelaide of all places
how do you know this off by heart
because it's just a fun fact about
Australia like telling people yeah so I
think it's like the University Adelaide
or something like that that invented
Wi-Fi
and for some reason we have the shittest
Wi-Fi like what what happened
um yeah I don't know about capitalism
that's what happened
yeah I mean like I was searching up some
other weird facts about Australia and
Melbourne as well yeah and I found out I
guess we also had this on the Australia
live stream that we did before uh that
Melbourne was almost called Bat Mania
yeah
did you guys know about this because of
uh the the founder John John Batman yeah
that just sounds like a meme there is no
way this is real we have only 500 places
named [__] in the UK and I think we're
like we're not one to judge I don't
think we've got to say I mean Australia
has some pretty fantastically named
townsends I still got to go there man I
still got to go yeah you don't there's
like 20 people who live there
it's in like the butt [__] middle of
nowhere in Queensland uh we also have uh
banana
in Queensland wait what we have a town
called banana anyone from banana no
anyone anyone from banana no one no no I
don't even think any of you have been to
banana
what is that
bananas why is it called okay actually I
was looking up some like other things
about Australia
um and I saw something about the big
banana or something oh yeah the national
pride that's the big banana now you guys
are oddly proud about do you want to
explain that I mean I don't know much
about it I know it's in Queensland
somewhere I was really disappointed when
I found out the big banana is not in
fact in banana I feel that was a missed
opportunity but yeah it's just this one
I guess
I don't know just I guess you know
Arabic huh mistake I guess yeah tourist
mistake I don't know uh where we just
have this giant sculpture of a banana
and apparently it's like the biggest
fruit sculpture in the world it's like
wow what a flex banana is the best thing
ever
maybe you should go to the big banana I
should yeah yeah although also actually
uh Connor you'd also hate that in New
South Wales we have a town called Orange
as well
Australia's too [__] big it is it is
it really is like I don't know like uh
there's there's some parts of Australia
that I always forget almost exist and I
know that's like a me like does
Australia really exist it's not real
let's not open that okay yeah uh but um
I don't know if this is just like a me
thing but I always forget that Darwin
exists
do you know what I mean this okay so
Australia uh has you know obviously same
as America split up into States all
right we're in Victoria right now
um and one of the states is called the
Northern Territory have a guess as to
why it's called that I don't know
because it's in the north
um and and the capital of the Northern
Territory is this town called Darwin
yeah I know but shout out to the sheep
in the audience yeah no like because the
Northern Territory has like massive
amounts of sheep
um but I mean I've never been there
before but like is that why he barged
yeah I was like I just thought he was
like yeah yeah it wasn't just like a
weirdo making a sheep but
um yeah so like the capital of obviously
the capital of Victoria is Melbourne
um and you know each state has the
capitals and the capital of the Northern
Territory is Darwin but the problem is
for one
who's who's been to Darwin before
okay well that's quite a lot about a lot
of people yeah yeah what the [__] is
there to do in Darwin nothing yeah
that's what I thought why did you guys
go then
oh I noticed that all you guys say is
nothing is there anything to do in
Melbourne
okay
maybe there's half nothing this episode
is sponsored by oxu Oxford lives the
experience of tasting authentic Japanese
snacks teas and candies so stretched
from Century old small family businesses
right to your door their mission is to
empower Japanese traditional snack
makers by sharing their authentic foods
and stories with the world the first
Boxer you'll receive is called The
Seasons of Japan following that every
single month you will get a brand new
theme sent directly to your door just
like this one this Box's theme is Midori
summer as always it comes with a
cultural booklet right here that tells
you all about the snacks where they come
from and maybe what the flavors are
every box who also comes with this
cultural guide that tells you all about
the snacks their Origins and the
cultural Roots as you guys know from all
the boxer reads you've already done I
love sembe and this one is the kyono
satoshiro Miso sembe so let's give it a
shot
oh my goodness shiromiso being white
miso it's kind of the standard miso soup
you'll get pretty much everywhere in
Japan and this is oh my God this goes
incredibly hard why is there only one in
this box I need more so to get 15 off
your very own boxu Japanese snack box
and support our Channel use our code
trashtaste at boxer.com that's
b-o-k-k-s-u.com that is
b-o-k-s-u.com with code trash taste to
get 15 off your first box
um this episode is sponsored by gamer
Subs boys if you need a clean energy
drink with no crashes no sugar and
tastes Godlike then make sure let's
check out Gamers up but John look after
my physique now man I don't need those
calories come on Joey shut the [__] up
God because gamer Subs is zero calorie
Energy Formula and is keto friendly and
diabetic friendly famous Subs has very
unique art flavors such as brand risk
and I think there's guacamole gamer fart
and what's this one gone it is they
don't sound very good but they are good
let us know what flavors you'd like to
see from Gamestop so maybe there's some
ideas in the comments below as to what
flavors we could have oh maybe trash
flavors garlic juice
Fuel and not only that you can drink a
great energy drink in this beautiful
waifu cups as well look at that mine's
got a really cute succubus you can
appreciate the culture while you fuel up
Gamers so get your own waifu cups at
gamersups.gg trash taste and use code
trash taste that is
g-a-m-e-r-s-u-p-b-s dot GG slash trash
taste thank you very much game myself
for sponsoring us today back to the
episode so it's like what is there to do
in Melbourne that does it involve
drinking
[Applause]
it is pretty it is pretty shocking how
how much gambling goes on in Australia
yeah we have the we have the highest
gambling addiction per capita apparently
so yay Aussies
thank you
no wonder our economy is [__] no it's
good for Casino for the casinos that's
great it's great it's great we actually
uh went to the casino yesterday right we
went to the crown yesterday uh we were
hanging out with I guess uh Chad from
the cold ones and where did he drag us
to the crown so Chad was an interesting
experience yeah Chad was like I gotta
Chad was like oh I gotta take gone and
Connor to the most Melbourne place ever
and he talks to the [__] Crown I'm
like well he's not wrong I guess but uh
yeah but no actually something funny
happened at the grounds didn't it
because
remember this
yeah because okay so uh we were with
Chad and some other YouTube content
creators like laser beam uh Lachlan as
well uh who are all like massive
creators in their own Fields like 20
million kind of like subscribers yeah uh
and Chad
sorry yes yes
[Applause]
uh and Chad apparently has been to the
crown so much that he has a black card
to get us into a private room it's so
disturbing yeah
uh but unfortunately you can't go into
this private room unless uh you're
wearing like I believe like a jeans or
proper trousers so you can't wear track
suits yeah there's like a really strict
like dress code yeah yeah and
unfortunately uh one of the producer
styles with us was wearing tracksuits at
the while uh at the time
and so we get in they check everyone's
ID and they start checking what we're
wearing and they see that our producers
wearing the tracksuit uh and they say
unfortunately we can't let you win and
as he's giving Joey's ID back it's this
is it was almost like a [__] meme he
just goes the anime man
oh my God
and then they [__] let us in
[Applause]
and he's like don't worry I'll pull some
strings for the anime man
and and to put things in perspective
this has never happened with Chad in the
history of him having a black art at all
he's been rejected so many times and
what broke that streak the anime man
so if you ever gamble take Joey yeah I
can I can get you in anywhere apparently
I couldn't [__] believe that like oh
my God it's like if you will a [__]
you know standing in a room with like
Barack Obama right and then the guys
Barack Obama in this situation like
Barack Obama is like the equivalent of
like you know laser beam and Lachlan and
channeling all these guys who clearly
have like I'm not even close to their
level right in terms of subs or like
just like how much like notoriety
they're having especially in Australia
right
and of course they point out the
[__] who watches anime
like yeah because actually this is the
second time this has happened in
Australia yeah yeah so when was the
first time this happened Joey I don't
know if I told this on trash days but it
was in Sydney uh when we were at Smash
and um and we're in um I forgot the name
of the it was like a pizza bar thank you
yeah Frankie's it was Frankie's Pizza
um it's just like in the CBD in Sydney
and I was with Chad again
and Ludwig
and it was the three of us and uh and
this and this like random dude who we
didn't know just like really like you
know when someone is so drunk that they
look sober
like where they're like beyond the point
of like oh he clearly looks strong to
the point where they're just like trying
to keep a straight face as much as
possible but it's way too obvious that
they just shit-faced this is what this
fourth guy looked like mind you none of
us knew who this guy was he just like
tagged along right so we're trying to go
in and obviously because it's a bar uh
we have to give her ID right
so we're giving our ID blah blah blah um
and then the fourth guy uh didn't have
his ID with him right for some reason I
don't know why and the bouncer was like
uh yeah so if he's with you and he
doesn't have your if he doesn't have his
ID we can't let you in now from what I
understand uh in Sydney a bit like
London yeah you cannot like the bounces
were not bend the rules no at all no
right but Chad Bean Chad was just like
oh can you do something about her maid
like we really want to go in and eat
some pizza so then the bouncer was like
all right let me call the manager so he
goes downstairs he grabs this manager
who is this like rocker chick like she
could she should have been to like a
thousand punk shows just like piercings
everywhere tats everywhere right
um and she's looking at all of us and
just being like uh okay so let me double
check your IDs again so checks me chat
and a lot of his ID and he looks at it
for a while gives it back to us and she
straight up goes all right I'll let you
in because you're the anime man
I'm like
there's a lot of weekend chatter just
saying they're like
what the [__]
then I got in
Fair it's not it's it's alert meanwhile
I I they scanned my bags like five times
at TSA because they know who I am
they're like oh we know you don't let
him in
this is what happens when the manager
meets the Karen yeah they're like let
him in let him in I don't want any
issues yeah she knew I was like Karen
she's like all right let the Karen in
there you go get him in yeah
like a lot of anime fans in Australia
is it like okay to be a wee or yeah I I
think I think you know much like the
rest of the world I feel like the time
that especially like you and I have done
uh YouTube I feel yeah because he's too
[__] because he's an old [__] yeah
old but like in the time that like
around when you and I started especially
in Australia and I'm sure in like the UK
as well and like in America and all that
kind of stuff it was like way way more
of a niche like it was it was kind of
like a like you'd get bullied in school
for watching anime yeah whereas I feel
today I still get bullied yeah exactly
watching anime but like I feel today
it's like I don't know would you say
it's like a little more accepted to
watch anime or I would say it is when
you guys were growing up was it like
very unacceptable and like you would get
kind of like belief that kind of thing
yeah all right I mean I got bullied to
[__] for it so you know did you actually
yeah but you're Japanese you have a
reason to be a weeb yeah but I I also
went to a school in the northern beaches
where I was the only even a remotely
Asian kid so like I go I go bullied like
first off for just being Asian in a
white school and then on top of that
when they found out I like this like
Japanese cartoon [__] they were like oh
extra ammunition for the fire and you
play video games and I play video games
I play jrpgs of all games so I was like
I was not helping my case but like I
feel now it's I don't know what like
what's it like in the UK like is it a
little more accepted so like I went
through a stage of just being a complete
closet weeb yeah right same uh because
also it wasn't just like not socially
accepted in my school and everything uh
my parents also like soft pressured me
to like stop a lot of times wait wait
wait you let your parents know you were
watching anyway of course I did bro I
did okay okay all right here's the
reason why okay uh
okay
into anime right yeah Crunchyroll didn't
exist I didn't really know that anime
was readily available on the internet
back then because it was it was just
before like the streaming like platforms
that really started rising up yeah yeah
uh so how I got my anime was basically
going through eBay and buying what I
thought was legitimate DVDs
but of course I was under 18. so every
time I wanted to watch a new show I was
like Mom can I borrow your credit cards
I wanna I wanna I wanna watch these uh
Japanese cartoons I want to watch Naruto
Shippuden
no no joke the first the first series I
ever bought was actually Naruto right
that was of course yeah okay and I
thought it was an official box there uh
so I thought I'd go on eBay I was like
oh brilliant Naruto episode one to
episode 200 and it's like 50 uh 50
pounds or something that's a deal that
why is this cheaper than every other
option on eBay right now
and so uh I borrowed my mom's credit
card I buy the DVDs uh and it shows up
and what I was expecting to be an
official box set it was just the [__]
CD case with handwritten Naruto episode
0 to 50 on like one one uh one CD yeah
and I don't think it was even a DVD it
was a vcd which is a video CD they're
probably people in this audience that
don't even know what that is yeah me a
vcd they were around when you were
around
you're not that young I remember we had
floppy discs in my house and I used to
think like what is this weird thing when
I slide the door and I didn't I I we I
didn't use it why does this not fit into
my DS I was just like uh-huh what is
this let me go and play on Miniclip
that was good did you miss the VHS era
no no no of course okay okay you're not
that young thank God you're not that
young man I used to like um
record Family Guy episodes my parents
wouldn't let me watch Family Guy so
how's it like I'd turn off the TV but it
would still record the channel yeah so I
would just leave it on and let it record
Family Guy and then I would wake up you
ripped Family Guy episodes onto VHS yeah
yeah damn that's get over yeah
it's awful quality as well I guess like
from in my case like I didn't really
have to like be closer to like to my
parents or anything because like my mom
was the one that introduced me to anime
growing up like trying to make your work
right oh yeah yeah she was like yeah he
looks like a weave this is the only way
he's gonna learn Japanese give him some
Doraemon he'll eat that [__] up
um yeah I know and it's great and um but
I think like I also had when I was a kid
uh this kind of like blank phase with
watching anime because it's like the
only access to anime that I had at the
time was just by either my mom grabbing
vhs's from Japan or my grandma basically
doing what you did where like she would
rip like anime on TV onto VHS and then
send me these like giant boxes to
Australia that would take like three
months by Freight God oh so like by the
time it arrived it was like already old
as [__] so they were like trying their
best to make you a weeb and they
succeeded so uh they must have known you
were gonna be the anime man
but like um yeah I don't think so I had
this like kind of blank phase where like
because I didn't have the knowledge uh
of like buying [__] off of eBay or
anything like that so like I think
the next time I started watching anime
was um when was it it was when uh only
only Australians would get this but
uh it was when they finally started
airing anime on cheese TV
which was this one uh what anime were
available ah there was there was Naruto
in like one piece uh Pokemon Yu-Gi-Oh
what else was there
quadcopters all quadcopter yeah card
Capital Sakura Sailor Moon reruns were
on there as well
um yeah and then like yeah Digimon and
there was just like they just kind of
kept growing out that uh thing so like
the only opportunity I got to watch
anime like in primary school was just
every Sunday morning I'd [__] wake my
sister up at like 6 a.m and just be like
latest episode of One Piece is on get up
and should be like [__] off so I would
just yeah just sit in front of the TV
for six hours every Sunday morning it
just like binge as much anime as
possible oh good old days how's the good
old days man is cheese TV still going
yeah is it called cheese cheese TV
cheese it used to be called toasted TV
and then it changed the cheese TV yeah I
don't know I don't get why
all the way around almost the other way
around
what a fake Australian huh wow was there
anything on TV that your parents didn't
let you watch uh
uh they didn't let me watch South Park
yeah makes sense makes sense checks out
and Family Guy that didn't let me watch
Family Guy yeah that's why I had to
sneak the VHS tips yeah yeah but let me
watch like Simpsons and Futurama
they wanted me to watch literally
anything but cartoons they thought
cartoons for like for kids even if it
was like Family Guy in South Park well
like how old were you at this point like
12. oh they were like you should watch
real people stuff stop being a kid and I
was like oh okay but I like The Simpsons
like well son sit down and watch Law and
Order with me they'd make me watch uh I
don't think you guys have this we had a
thing called like I'm a celebrity get me
out of here do you guys oh I remember
that they would film that in Australia
though yeah what is it yeah they would
basically just send like [__] detier
British celebrities through the
Australian jungle and they're like look
spider and they go
and they're like now you've got to hold
spider like oh no
and then they hold it you're like oh and
then you vote it's essential areas no
it's terrible it's so bad I love when
non-australians react to just because
like I've tried to convince so many of
my friends especially Japanese friends
to come to Australia and the first thing
they always say is like yeah but the
spiders
is it that bad I have I haven't seen one
yeah it's not that bad right no how many
of you have actually had an experience
with a spider in your house like a [__]
off oh you you're absolute liar you
absolute lives all right all right oh
it's not that bad is it like once a year
twice a year it's like once a month
right yeah once a month yeah no burning
the [__] house down no but no but I I
can explain I can explain uh because uh
because you know we have tons of
different spiders right but the the
spider that always [__] shows up into
the house is the huntsman spider
[Applause]
because the huntsman spider is an
Australian's best friend oh okay okay
why is it Australia's best friend
because I've seen pictures of the Hansen
yeah
I'm not gonna lie they look terrifying
but the the huntsman spider is good
because
um if you see a huntsman spider on your
wall or your ceiling or whatever that
means that you have either an
infestation of flies or mosquitoes in
your house and the Huntsman spider makes
a bro move and he's like dog don't worry
about it I'm gonna eat them all and then
get the [__] out I no they don't so what
you do is if you see a huntsman spider
on your wall or your ceiling you just
leave him be [__] off no I do you leave
him be because it's like he's he's
cleaning up this is this true is that
what you guys do no it's not yes it is
you are you telling me if there was like
four giant spiders above your like bed
you're like ah just I'll leave Steve to
the morning
did the
[__] go in you know like brush them away
and then they'll just [__] run away
so it's like I used to have one as a pet
all right so wait
I used to catch flies rip off their
wings and then give it to the Huntsman
oh
yeah yeah no wonder it's not [__]
leaving your house and then we get a
four meal course every day and then one
day I woke up and he was gone and I was
like good knowing you bro
he's moved on to a different house
so what spiders do we need to look out
for war animals in like your day-to-day
life so so the rule of thumb with like
spiders or snakes in Australia is that
the more colorful they are the more
[__] up they are so we have uh so we
have the uh the red back spider
which is like you don't [__] with him
what is it what do you get bitten by
what happens you die
okay it's straight up all right
important question is this tour in
school like Australian school okay okay
yeah very good I used to in my
kindergarten uh there was this massive
uh poster of like all the different
species of uh like commonly seen spiders
and snakes uh that they would just like
have on the wall and I remember some
like lessons we were like three or four
years old I don't know if this was just
my kindergarten but it was like big like
A3 poster of all these snakes and
spiders and they'd be like okay kids if
you see any of these then cry to your
mum and dad and Don't Go Near any of
them because you will die and all the
kids are like okay it's like it's just
ingrained into as an Australian because
it's like survival the fittest in this
country that's why we only have 26
million people who live how the [__] how
the [__] did any of those like British
people that came here like survive I
just feel like we're just not built for
this no no like the worst we have is
like a goose
just like it's it's like oh yeah
we don't have deer we don't have deer we
don't have them you guys have foxes all
right yeah but foxes bro every dude this
is okay I'm gonna rant now because this
is like children books making foxes seem
like they're the worst thing ever yeah
they don't [__]
like a big they're like [__] that
I'm gonna go get like a sheep they can't
do anything they don't do anything and
half the time when I saw them in London
they were just in the trash
that's like the common misception with
snakes and spiders in Australia as well
is that like snakes are [__] [__]
like they like if you the only reason
why they bite people is for defense
mechanism it's because people are going
up to them being like oh look at the
[__] snake and then they just start
like slapping this [__] around and it's
like yeah that's a typical Aussie thing
to do right it's like it's like no
wonder you're getting bit and you're
harassing the hell out of six alone and
it won't do anything
have you ever needed to get rid of a
snake in your house uh yeah
who's had a snake in their house yeah
that's right all right do you have to do
it yourself or is there like someone to
call to get ready have I told this story
on trash day so I don't remember no
you've never told a snake Okay so uh
trash days it was so there's been a
couple of instances but the one that's
just forever ingrained into my mind is
uh I was in high school I was like year
10 or something and I was coming back
from school and because both my parents
were working you know they'd come back
like at night so I would usually be the
first one home so I I'd walk in and uh
my my entrance way was basically this
like two-door system whereas like we had
a steel gate that you'd open okay okay
yeah and then you'd walk in take your
shoes off and then there'd be the main
door to get into the house see that's
how you know the country is [__] up
little bugs and [__] yeah in the UK we
don't have that we barely have a door it
barely works half the time so there was
the the two things right so you'd have
to open the gate first before you could
the door
um and so I I put the key in I unlock it
and I try and open it and it's just like
not moving at all it's like kind of
stuck and I'm like [__] I unlocked it
what's going on and I'm looking around
and I look up and there's a tree snake
right here
like looking at my face
um and the first instinct as an
Australian is not oh [__] that's a snake
it's [__] I don't know if that's
venomous or not
so what I did in a fit of panic I don't
know if you've ever just like looked
over and the snake's face is just right
here but it scares the [__] out of you
right so I I'm like oh [__] I swing it
open and the snake runs behind the uh
the the shoe cabinet
right and I'm like and and now I'm in a
pickle I'm like well I can't open the
main entrance because the snake's
probably gonna get in and that's just a
whole other issue and also I don't want
to do anything to the snake because I
I'm not smart enough to identify what it
is all right so I don't know if it's
stupid I can't do anything so I'm just
like I don't know if that's venomous or
not I'm not gonna do anything but in
Australia I don't know if you guys have
this in Melbourne but uh there is a
hotline that you can call uh called
snake Patrol
they really they really couldn't think
of a better name yeah no well I mean the
name speaks for itself right so I'm like
so I remembered I was like that's right
we have snake Patrol here so I called
him up and I'm like uh and and this like
real [__] Yobo like answers the phone
and he's just like oh wait what
I'll explain I'll explain that to you
later
that's the phone old guy and he was just
like uh and I was like oh yeah uh I got
a snake uh and I I need help and he was
like all right I'll be there in five
minutes
and uh sure enough five minutes later
this guy comes out rocks up walks
towards the door and he's like all right
where's the [__] snake
and I'm just like uh right there and he
just like he looks down like this looks
at it for about 20 seconds and he's like
oh yeah that's a tree snake
and then he walks off
so all the snake Patrol is there to do
is to basically identify if the snake is
poisonous or not if it is poisonous then
he'll go to his truck and get all the
necessary like tools to remove it safely
if it's not poisonous then he's like you
can do it
so basically what I had to do was you
know I'm like 15 16 right like I'm like
okay I know this thing isn't gonna kill
me but I don't I don't want to get
bitten it'll still hurt so I was
basically just like sitting there for 40
minutes just staring at this thing
waiting for my dad to come home and I'm
like don't you [__] move my dad's
gonna
sure enough my dad walks up I tell him
the situation my dad does the exact same
thing like does this
I was like oh yeah that's a tree snake
walks off no
and uh and my dad just literally just
pulls his arm under
grabs the snake
like in the hand and just goes all right
get in
and that's the moment I knew to never
[__] with my dad
and that's a and I feel that's a very uh
I feel that's a very common story you'd
hear in Australia is because sometimes
snakes get curious and they're like oh
this looks like a warm comfortable home
I can turn into my newer mode let's
let's try and get in and then yeah so
like all those videos You See online of
like snakes in the kitchen it's quite
common
[__] you know especially if you're in
like rural Australia like that [__]
happens all the time
one thing I am actually jealous of uh
not the snakes not the spiders I'm not
jealous of that uh but it's the amount
of like but different birds you have
here oh yeah in England we have like
pigeons and seagulls I remember like the
first time I landed in Sydney I I
thought it was like a city I'm used to
like seeing some exotic birds and the
first thing I see was I believe like I
didn't know what it was I just saw a
bird with a really long thin beak I
don't know and then I look at it and I'm
like
and then cities like gone what are you
looking at and then she looks at it and
she goes what the [__] is that
that's that's cool that's called a bin
chicken yeah
that is just the weirdest [__] thing
it is the weirdest thing they're an
absolute nuisance as well I
I just can't believe they exist
like I feel like every other country
there would have been something that
just got rid of them by accident you
know like the UK would just have
annoying little kids they would piss
them off they'd be like oh [__] this
we're going back in the country no but
the problem with the bean chickens is
that they're so big that the kids are
like I don't want to go anywhere yeah
big they're walking around like little
toddlers it's so weird
it's because they just like as the name
suggests they just go into the bins and
they just [__] they're basically like
our equivalent of crows I mean we have
that you know we have the the
um what are the black birds that we have
here again magpies thank you yeah
magpies are kind of [__] is that true
oh yeah in fact I think it's like I read
a study that said like uh magpies were
like I think number one or number two
biggest reason as to why cyclists get
into accidents
because they because that this such [__]
cons are let me tell you
magpies right they do this thing called
swooping right which is basically
they're so incredibly territorial that
if you go even in like a 10 kilometer
radius of their nest they're just like
that's a threat and they just start
swooping you and so cyclists who are
like just you know having a casual
Sunday morning cycle just gets swooped
by these magpies and they [__] go ass
over time and they [__] die just dive
bomb them yeah they dive bomb them oh my
God yeah who's been dive bombed by
Magpie before yeah thank you
another another yeah yeah so kind of
cyclathon in Australia right
[Applause]
is going to turn up in a full suit of
armor and he's like okay I am ready now
okay let's let's hypothetically let's
say I was like I was stupid enough to
say yes okay and I'm I'm ready to fight
off every single dangerous animal and
[__] I I can't even sleep in my hotel
room without fear of being killed by a
spider okay
your internet is so [__] [__] here
I'll be like hey guys uh well welcome
back to the stream all right I'll see
you guys in two hours when I get near a
telephone uh Tower also I okay so in
Japan right when you cycle between uh
the cities it's like oh everything's
about 50 to 100 kilometers separate yeah
in Australia it's like all right
two days into the cycle of fun and we
still haven't left Sydney four days in I
still haven't got to the next city maybe
nine days in we'll finally reach another
city and it'll be [__] Canberra yeah
oh [__] this I'm going home
yeah I feel I've always thought about
that like if you were to do a cyclathon
in Australia what would be like the most
optimal route because it's like cycling
from Sydney to Canberra would be nice
while you're in Sydney for the first
three days but then after that it's like
[__] all like it's not like what I don't
know I don't know like because Australia
I mean Australia is massive yeah right
cycling isn't the most optimal way to
get around this country yeah especially
with all of the dangers that you'll have
to work time events magpies yep
exactly yeah I don't think it'll be
doable to be honest with you maybe maybe
if you like went from one end of Sydney
to the other maybe but that wouldn't be
much fun that would be [__] yeah imagine
how you'd advertise that I cycle all of
Sydney Australians are like wow the rest
of the rest of the world is like you
cycle the city
the [__] what other kind of birds are
there here in Australia though you get
to regularly see birds in Australia
um obviously we have cockatoos uh yeah
we just see flocks of them here yes it's
it's it's so weird because this is such
an exotic bird that you know you rarely
get to see they sound like their cry
sounds like a chain smoker trying to
hack up a loogie you know it's like ah
it's like it's my god when you're woken
up by that at like five five in the
morning it's just like oh my God I'm
gonna kill these birds and then uh we
have the Kookaburra as well uh which is
a bird that the cry sounds like it's
laughing what type of bird is the one
you have as a pet uh I had a cockatiel
which is just like a small it's like a
baby cockatoo no it looked like an SS
tiered skin of a pigeon
it looks so cool like our birds all suck
in the UK we just have pigeons like we
have pigeons and seagulls here but you
guys have other tears you have like SS
tear birds like this yeah you guys
actually have like a drop rate with like
different tiers of birds we have two and
they're both like one Stars yeah
seagulls and pigeons
I don't know what would be the most
exotic bird you'd see because you you
are like often coming to your house for
the first time you actually convinced me
when I'm able to get one I'm definitely
gonna get a bird as a pair oh yeah like
oh does anyone have a pet bird
I have another bird story after my
previous Bird Story involving a bird in
Thailand yeah uh I saw the saddest thing
I've ever seen in my life okay uh in my
entire house last month when I was
living there uh so in my entire house
it's kind of out of the city so it's
kind of like closer to the outskirts
it's closer to Nature uh so we see a lot
of wildlife there we have had massive
snakes that we've had to get rid of our
uh get rid of our snakes in our house as
well uh we we get a lot of birds as well
uh and there's one time I was just
chilling out my hammock uh in my
backyard and I see two birds in front of
me uh one's just sitting there and there
is another bird who I assumed to be a
male bird doing some kind of mating
dance so he had he had his wings out
like this
kind of like this yeah just just doing
this
oh is that is that like the black birds
sorry is are they like the black birds I
think so yeah I think I know what you're
talking about yeah so he was dancing uh
in front of this other bird for a
full-on 10 minutes
uh and then after about 10-15 minutes
the other bird just flies off
and I've never wanted
flew off yes
I've never wanted to give a bird a hug
so badly in my life because all he did
was just slowly put his wings back
didn't even fly off and just walked off
to a to a bush that's that's just me
every time I'm at a club
I danced for 10 minutes the woman walks
off and I'm like I'll get a beer that
was just like a bro moment in real life
I was like bro it's okay man it's okay
you'll find another one there's another
one don't worry there's so many stories
with animals
I'm in Australia well do you not have
any I thought what are the animal played
games and watched anime why are we why
are we interacting with someone's nature
what are the animals that you commonly
find in Wales
yeah yeah what's uh what's a Welsh part
uh past time
well what do you what do you guys do
sometimes you'll be on the train and
then it'll be like sorry there is a
sheep on the track we cannot continue
it's real that happens a lot and you're
like well how do we move it you're like
you don't
it just moves well you don't bully the
Sheep can't be that big right you could
just get someone to just push it you
can't push a sheep they're [__] big
just get like three people to just be
like out of the way
all right good Gavin Steve
all the train conductors are like all
right come on let's go move this [__]
they'll eventually move
wait okay so you said you've experienced
that before right yeah many times what's
the longest you've had to wait for a
sheep to move like 40 minutes
oh my God because sometimes it's like
they bring all their friends
and they're all Crossing because
sometimes the trains go through like
someone's Farmland yeah so then it's
just like oh you're just slowly watching
them go and then they're like ah let's
go back
oh my god oh okay but yeah that happens
um other than that just it's like it's
like eventually over to like a
difficulty slider of of like Wildlife
yeah Wales is like putting it all the
way down to zero and Australia is like
cranking it to ten yeah and then putting
like nightmare mode on top of it yeah
it's like we don't have anything that's
really dangerous we just had like Rams
do you guys have Rams do we have Rams
there's like a bit of really angry I
think I think we do have Rams but you'd
have to go out to like rural Australia
to find those and like no one [__]
lives out there I was like uh I was
shopping one time at this local um like
I don't know like a corner store it was
kind of far out and I was just there and
I went outside of the store and as I
came out of the store there was just a
ram
just on the road oh I've I've had that
civil experience but with a kangaroo
Australian moment I was I was at my
local IGA represent
okay well what is that what's an IGA
it's like it's like a corner store oh
okay uh yeah so I was at my local IGA
and I walked in to just by like I don't
know what I was buying some chips or
something uh and I walk out and I turn
the corner and there's just like a route
the standing there on the sidewalk and
I've never had there was the most
awkward moment it's like when you like
meet an ex you know you just I'm just
standing there just maintaining eye
contact with this rude not saying
anything I'm like
so who's gonna who's gonna make the
first move here like you ran right no I
just I was I just saw him and I'm like
all right he's not gonna do anything so
I just walked back to my car and the
room was just chilling there he wasn't
doing anything like when I say Rue right
like I think most foreigners when they
think of like kangaroos they think of
like the red kangaroos like the [__]
like yeah like [__] house Kanger is
right like those guys you only really
see when you go out into like rural
Australia where I'm from uh because my
my backyard was next to a national park
so we got a lot of like kind of smaller
Kangaroos and a lot of like rock
wallabies uh which are like just it's
like they probably stand about that tall
they're really really cute yeah
wallabies all right yeah they're just
like small kangaroos basically
um but I remember the first time we used
to get rock wallabies coming into my
backyard
um and you know just like hang out and
stuff and my dad would be like just to
hang out just come to hang out yeah
there's like oh there's lots of wildlife
here let's just hang out see what's
happening
um and I remember there was this like
rock wallaby that came out uh and my dad
was like son
you should go feed him
and I was like five and I'm like Dad I'm
not too sure man he's like the same size
as me
and he's like nah that's a real quality
you want to [__] you up don't worry so
he gave me some bread
and it's just this like it's just this
moment of just like slowly walking up to
this rock wall with me just hand shaking
being like eat it please don't kill me
and then the moment the rock wallaby
took it out of my hand I was like oh God
is real
yeah well when you're five years old
dude everything is magical and when you
see this like [__] Rottweiler be the
same size as you'd just be like thank
you for the gift human it's like it's
like oh you know what animals are kind
of cool
I don't know that's the moment I'm sure
every Australian has had this moment
where like is it okay is it a common
stereotype
that all Australians love animals yes I
mean I feel like you have to because
it's the survival you have no choice
right
do you guys like animals
yeah is anyone who doesn't like animals
you're in the wrong country
yeah I mean uh I remember the first time
I saw a kangaroo because I've obviously
seen kangaroos on television and stuff
like that uh and then I basically you
know when I went to visit my family in
Melbourne last time I was here I saw one
for the first time and actually just
seeing one in real life just moving
around I'm like my first instinct was
like that's [__] up and let me explain
let me let me cook let me cook for a
second let me cook because I I just just
seeing this kangaroo move around I'm
like okay let me let me try to process
this so in the entire history of Earth
natural selection uh with animals
everyone everyone in every different
continent animals decided yeah all right
let's walk on four legs all right that's
just the way to get around unless you're
a gym then you walk on two legs all
right uh and then in this island called
Australia a little consonant [__]
kangaroos are like yeah just [__]
bounce
how does that make sense how does that
make sense how did natural selection get
to this point they decided to do that
well sometimes kangaroos do actually
walk on four legs they kind of like use
their front two legs like that and they
just kind of Bounce like that
if you know like but that's their
equivalent of like a Sunday morning walk
you know or when they need a [__]
move they're just like all right [__]
the front legs let's go you know so I
mean yeah it is
watching a kangaroo was it was because
like it was so weird because it was just
like there was just one deer that just
squat decided I'm gonna do leg day I
just started squatting and that's what
that's why I believe like kangaroos came
from every day is leg day with the
kangaroo isn't the deadliest animal uh
that bird the one that looks like an
ostrich oh the cassowary yeah that one
yeah I think it's the yeah the world's
most dangerous that's not a bird that's
a dinosaur well it's like it is
threatening it's scary I remember when I
was uh up in Cairns one time uh which is
like wait where cans like in France no
yeah right that's the most Australian
spelling Cairns uh it's like it's it's
basically right where like the Great
Barrier Reef is okay um so when I went
there in Cairns uh I went my family and
I went on this like kind of rainforest
Safari type of thing where uh we we
rented out like a a a
buggy like a full it's basically like
think of a golf cart except it was
four-wheel drive so we're riding through
this and uh and we had the ranger that
was with us you know doing like a guided
tour being like this is the great
rainforests of Cairns and it's beautiful
and it's humid as [__] and I want to die
and and he just stopped the car and he
was like
guys it's your lucky day
that right there
is a wild cassowary
and we look over and this thing is just
giving us the Luigi Death Stare like
just he's like you are not supposed to
be here
and I think even the ranger figured that
out because he after he said that he
paused for like two seconds and he's
like
we should go
they run this town dude it's so scary
because like they have uh they have a
razor beak right yeah it's like super
short actually the most dangerous thing
about it is it's feet because it has
these like three giant claws that uses
it to kick and uh apparently if you get
kicked by a castleware you're just like
you're just done it just looks like a
dinosaur that forgot to die during the
yeah they're like oh [__] where's all my
mates go
are you saying we're the strongest now
oh don't mind if I do I think I'll stick
around thank you very much yeah no
they're scary yeah one thing I've always
been curious about uh going back to
spiders and snakes is what are you
taught to do if you get bitten by one
like what are you actually taught to do
just if we see one I don't know if you
get actually get bitten by one oh
um
yeah just give up just pray
um I think uh there was a lot of like TV
shows when I was growing up that were
kind of like because you know I loved
watching like Nature Documentaries like
you know the David attenboroughs and uh
you know all those and I think I
remember one of the shows that that was
on I forgot the name of it but it was
basically like kind of survival like
Australian survival documentary of some
sort whereas like what should you do if
you're out in the desert and you get
bitten by a spider or you get bitten by
snake like here are the procedures that
you need to go through and I think I
remember I think with a spider or a
snake if you say like get bitten in like
the arm uh I think the first thing
you're supposed to do is like you're
supposed to like wrap up like get it get
your T-shirt or something wrap up your
arm as tight as you can so that the
Venom doesn't go to the rest of your
body this is true it's some something
like that right has anyone had to do
this
yeah holy [__] who's been bitten by a
snake before
um
right I'm correcting that yeah yeah so I
yeah so you you're supposed to wrap it
up with like a cloth of some kind as
tight as you can so that the Venom
doesn't run through the rest of your
body and then obviously if you have
reception you gotta [__] I feel like
this really should have been given to me
on my flight this information like I I
feel really unprepared welcome to
Australia yeah you get bitten by a
venomous snake
yeah the only thing they taught me was
like please don't you dare bring an
apple in our country we will [__] we
will kill you do you have any do you
have any seeds have you eaten any seeds
are you sure you didn't bring anything
in the country
yeah we're very uh we're very tired
asses on that I mean it makes sense like
uh because you know Australia has such a
I know yeah environment where it's like
but yeah I've never seen such intensity
oh yeah I mean I think because it's
happened once before yeah that's the
reason why we have [__] cane toads
everywhere is because some [__]
brought in an insect that ate all of our
cane sugar and was just like we got to
get rid of these I think they're flies
on mosquitoes I forgot what they were
um but you know they were destroying our
uh our sugar cane which is like I think
we make the most men sugarcane in the
world or something or we export the most
or something
um but these flies are just like
completely destroying all these crops
right there's nothing in the at the time
the current Australian like Animal
Kingdom that ate these pests right so
then some Australian politician or
something was just like so I've heard
that overseas uh there's a specific type
of toad that eats these [__]
we should bring them in
the Australian government was like
that's a great idea Steve let's do it
so then they introduced these cane toads
and sure enough it wipes out all the the
Flies right but then I guess Steve
didn't think it through that the cane
toad is also venomous and nothing eats
it
so now we just have an infestation of
cane toads that are just [__] up the
country and they're like well
not much we can do about that eh it's
just uh kind of [__] up uh so next
time I think they should just don't
bring any apples in they should just
keep upping it we should find something
else that could get rid of the cane too
yeah and then have another thing ready
to get rid of that thing oh there is
it's called humans okay yeah but you're
gonna lose that war if you uh try right
I mean you lost the Emu War
so
I think you're gonna do any better
against cane toads you guys don't have a
good track record against animals no we
don't I mean could you blame us like
we're the visitors
humans are merely the visitors to this
country it's an animal kingdom here but
that's what I think that's what like I
think that's what uh at least for me
that's what got me really interested in
just like learning about animals at a
young age is because when I found out
that like oh Australia has this like
such cool unique set of animals that
yeah yeah could kill me at any day but
it's just a casual could kill me
anything casual my life could end but
it's also just super fascinating to like
learn about because it's I don't know
it's [__] cool right right yeah all
right yeah speaking of Aussie things
though I did find a list I don't know if
this is accurate but I feel like since
we have a live crowd uh we can test how
accurate it is okay uh because it's a
list of things most Aussie do uh most
Aussies do that you guys now consider
normal
sir okay I want to test this out sure
okay okay so number one
see the traffic cone on the side of the
road to take home
why why are you proud of this because
everybody has done this first of all
they're called witch's hats
we don't call them traffic cones
is it this widespread I thought it was
because in England we still do it but
only like uni age you know that's that's
a uni thing to do I don't know wasn't it
like Trafalgar Square where they kept
putting it on top of it like this this
like 20 meter tall statue yeah they just
kept getting a cone on top of it no one
knew how and they could whenever they
removed it some dude just put it back
that's amazing no one knows how I love
that all right number two I I saw this
and I was like I've never heard of
anyone do this before so this might just
be the list okay hang a sack of wine to
a clothesline
so I found out that different states
call it different things so what do you
guys call it in Melbourne foreign
like the actual game of putting it on
the clothesline and spinning it around
you know the game I'm talking about wait
hold on a fortune right I've missed like
five steps okay okay let me explain let
me see let me explain so
here's another Australia is known for
advancing a lot of things like that have
helped the world this is something that
should not be invented we invented Wi-Fi
great invention we invented the
lawnmower great invention we also
invented the Goon
which is just our way of calling uh wine
which is really [__] wine you put it
into a bag and then you stuff that into
a box it's basically box wine but we
call it goon and there is a uh and also
because Australia is such a heavy
drinking culture we come up with a lot
of
really dumb drinking games and one of
them uh is called goona Fortune
um which is basically uh you know those
like cloth uh hang uh what is it the the
the clothing lines right that you can
spin
have you do you know these wait what no
okay I found out only Australia has this
so basically in your backyard there is
this like a clothesline but it's this
like think of like a giant uh like
parasol essentially it's the shape of a
parasol but if there's like clotheslines
on it and you can spin it
I don't know why why would you want to
spin it to play goon a fortune obviously
of course so basically goona Fortune is
this game where you you if your mate uh
has a spinning clothesline in their
backyard and someone has a goon sack
which everyone does
um you you pin up the Goon sack onto
this uh thing everybody stands around
the clothesline and then just like Wheel
of Fortune which is what it's named
after you spin the clothesline and
wherever the goonsack stops you've got
to take a sip
so how does this involve wine when when
do we get wine how are you supposed to
hang a beer
why do you want to hang a beer well
that's what I'm saying you got to hang
it to the clothesline right and a goon
bag is just in a bag so it's really easy
to hang up also it tastes like [__] so
no one wants to do it right which is the
whole point of a drinking game this
sounds so bad I know I I feel like this
is your way of sticking it to the French
I'm convinced that's it
everyone has their own way right
everyone has their own okay Alice is
good a fortune number three of course I
heard it was this one before drink
alcohol out of a shoe yep good old chewy
who here has actually done a Shoei
that is that guy does a chewy every
morning
I can't start my morning without a Shoei
uh yeah Chewie's uh horrible don't don't
yeah I'm actually glad because the ratio
of you guys that have done a shoe he
wasn't as high as I thought it was oh no
but that's nasty no that's because we're
in a city
oh and there's things to do in a city
when you're in rural Australia there's
nothing to do other than do a Shoei
all right uh number four is mix
chocolate and Vegemite
[Applause]
I don't know
I read that in it who's done this before
yeah yeah
[__] that's that's horrendous I mean
like okay Vegemite is already this one
thing that divides Australians like it's
like not toy in Japan right like not
every Japanese person likes nato in the
same way not every Australian likes
Vegemite who he likes Vegemite
I like Vegemite and it's really good
okay maybe I was wrong
the most common at least my midnight
snack when I was in uni was Vegemite and
cheese sandwiches
yeah that's the [__] you take some you
take a slice of light nice big of cheese
and you put some Vegemite on it two
pieces of bread you bite on that [__] oh
instant nut it's so good I like how you
to tell me what a Vegemite and cheese
sandwich was like how like like I
wouldn't have known how to build yeah
those two ingredients just in case you
did two pieces of bread just in case you
didn't know thank you for clarifying I
have I don't know what kind of psychotic
person would mix chocolate with Vegemite
though that sounds
that's uh he's a word you can learn in
Australia that sounds rank
what else what else yeah all right uh
you can have to explain this one I don't
know if this is part of Australian
history yeah but have a national debate
about sausage sandwiches
[Applause]
wait
what to what level are we talking
National debate I have no idea this is
just what the list said I mean guys that
are passionate about sausage sandwiches
or is there a point you know I mean
everyone knows how good the Bunnings
sandwich is all right
yeah
so bunny so we have this uh hardware
store called Bunnings Warehouse uh
lowest prices uh every day
um and every Sunday morning they uh they
basically just pull a barbecue out and
they give out sausage sandwiches to
people
um I used to get Sunday lunches there
all the time that sounds good yeah it's
great
um I don't know about like the debate
thing because like how I don't know
maybe it's like do you like onion on it
or I think maybe this
[Applause]
all onions all right
is that the debate
[Applause]
oh oh okay thank you yeah the debate is
do you use two slices of bread to
sandwich the sausage or do you use one
slice of bread
yeah
that I think I think that's the debate
explain it again explain it again okay
so in Australia how we do it is we don't
waste bread right we want to eat the
[__] sausage so we take one slice of
bread kind of put it like diagonally put
the sausage diagonally in the middle and
then fold it up like a like a year what
and that's a sausage sandwich right most
other countries though use two slices of
bread and to kind of sandwich it
together yeah right yeah but not in
Australia
you know what I'm on the Aussie side of
things I use one slice I use one slice
because we have to do this every time I
have a barbecue in England yeah I am
back every everyone makes a sausage
sandwich in England which we sometimes
think when we have a barbecue yeah and
everyone uses two slices of bread if we
don't have hot dog breads but I'm that
guy who just uses the one slice I don't
know it's just optimized two bread of
yeah it's me okay two slices of bread is
too much yeah it's easy it's easy to
hold it's just like listen you're just
lazy all right
I get it it's a lot of work I I also you
know I get fancy I cut the sausages in
half so they stay still and it's dude
it's so much fun
okay okay let me okay okay hold on
though I have a fact about Australia
okay
what now you're gonna
I I again this might have been I made it
the [__] up I I heard
[__] stupid I heard that one of your
Prime Ministers shed himself in a
McDonald's
yeah
now that's the man I can vote for
[Applause]
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding
yeah
[__] himself in a McDonald's
which one oh scomo yeah yeah Scoma Scott
Morrison we call him Scoma he [__]
himself in a McDonald's he [__] himself
in a McDonald's
I mean average day at a McDonald's if
you ask me so so uh are we proud of this
that uh
I mean what other country can say like
how prime minister [__] himself there
was also like one of your Prime
Ministers was had the quickest uh pint
drinking time or something
like how the
deciding your prime minister
by that clearly
it's like whoever won the box wine gets
to run the country yeah well I mean John
Howard won because he had the thickest
eyebrows right what yeah we had it we
had a prime minister called John Howard
and he had these like [__]
caterpillars it's okay I mean it's
insanely thick well we picked our prime
minister based on how stupid they are so
don't worry
about it join the club is uh part of the
election process having to do a Shoei at
this point like what what's that I mean
if you ask me they should bring that in
to be honest like I feel if you're a
true Australian you can do a Shoei and
come out on top and be like yeah that
was nothing give me another one funeral
fortune next this is a terrible way of
getting a private that's a terrible idea
uh all right next one this was pretty
random uh make coffee in avocado
I have never heard about that all right
all right that's some like rural
Australia [__] like okay I mean
especially here in Melbourne that has
like I would say yeah especially they
wouldn't do that in Melbourne especially
when I would say you guys have the best
coffee in the [__] world
honestly Conor you're the coffee guy
three of us good what do you think it's
pretty good it's pretty good it's pretty
good it's kind of crazy how much good
coffee there is just everywhere yeah
it's so unfair [__] you guys man
[__] you he don't miss all right well
that okay that that whole coffee and
avocado thing I don't know
hold on I'm tired of Australia
I don't want to talk about it anymore
why I want to talk about it anime
are we doing it are we actually talking
about on trash face I just wanna listen
it feels like such a waste to have a
studio audience and not see some anime
opinions you know what I mean right for
example let me just let me just say
something and you guys react to how it
makes you feel okay
spy family
is mid
[Applause]
Gotti I just wanted to try it I'm sorry
okay all right actually it's funny that
you brought it up because I feel like
for the first time in about 10 years uh
the boys come up to me like last week uh
and Joe and Joey especially get uh Joey
especially says gone you're not going to
believe this okay I go what he said I
watched 15 episodes of anime last week I
was like no way the anime man there's no
way
that's right I'm back baby he's back
yeah
um I just had like a day off one weekend
this is like a few days before we flew
to Melbourne
um and I was just like yeah
I don't know what's come over me but
I wanna I wanna watch anime disgusting
and I think it's because especially this
season is just so incredibly stacked
where I'm just like okay there's I feel
there's too many good shows not to watch
so I watched uh first at the time there
was only two episodes of oshinoko
[Applause]
let's say about that it's [__]
incredible currently it's yeah yeah the
manga was so freaking good so I knew it
was going to be good uh I watched uh
what's called English hell's Paradise
hell's Paradise Paradise which is also
like mapper never misses so they killed
her with that and I actually finally
finished an anime that I had had on hold
for the longest time oh oh okay and
because it was so long I I decided to
just go back to episode one and just
like binge all 12 episodes I finally
finished botching the Rock
yeah you finished watching the rock yeah
because I think I'd watch it up to like
episode five or six and then I just like
forgot about and I was like I
actually just kind of finished this so I
just binged in one day and uh yeah it's
good
but
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait Joey Joey what what do you
mean but
but
it is so incredibly cringe
okay okay I'm sorry you like that I mean
I found that yes it is incredibly
incredibly cringe but it was kind of
like
a self-reflective cringe because it was
so relatable that I found myself
cringing at some some points in it and
it was kind of like the closest thing I
found to something like peep show or
in-betweeners but like anime form where
I would watch scenes and I'd be like
this is so [__] painful yeah yeah
okay so like when I went into Bocce the
Royal cry that initially before I
decided to watch it all again right my
my understanding of it after reading the
synopsis I was like oh this is chaon but
if the main character was the girl from
watamote
which Bocce fans
that's what the show is
there's no denying that that's exactly
what that show is right it is a
incredibly socially awkward girl
making a band and making music this is
all the things I hate
to everything I don't stand so I went
into it right and look granted the art
and animation is phenomenal like I can I
can see why people adore this show right
but you pointed out saying oh I cringe
at the fact that it was relatable yeah
no one is that socially awkward I'm
sorry not even anime fans and that's
stooping low no one not not even anime
fans of that socially all is anyone that
socially awkward no no you think you are
that's [__] no no no you put your
hand up you put your hand up you're
already more sociable okay
do you guys like grocery the rock or
what are you feeling
okay good I like you guys yeah okay
like I granted like I understand why the
show is incredibly popular right because
you know there was a lot of aspects of
the show I really enjoy like the music
is [__] Stellar like especially that
last episode when they do those like
full performances of those songs I was
like hell yeah this is great [__]
music it's like chaon but they're
actually grinding man they're actually
working towards something and I respect
that okay yeah and I totally respected
that as well but like I don't know up
until like around like episode five and
six I just got so so frustrated at the
main character I was just like look I
know how this is gonna go all right
you're gonna go into your own world
thinking about all the horrible what ifs
of this like one social situation which
at the end of the day doesn't even
[__] matter right and then you're
gonna come out of it and you're going to
be like oh you know what it was fine all
along that's how every episode ends in
brought you the Rock and I'm like all
right can we just like hurry up please
can you just like get to the music
making process I much prefer that
I don't know is that a hot take
no do you like do you think do you think
it's overrated
yes
I haven't seen it
I'm just saying yes after I finally
finished it I think I could definitively
say
it's slightly overrated
okay actually the more important
question yeah which ones prefer Bocce
the rock or chaos K on 100 percent
I'm sorry no I can't no man okay here's
the thing okay here's the thing okay
explain yourself take a moment to
appreciate that we're [__] talking
about Adam yeah in front of like too
many people why do we care about this
okay here's the thing right I don't
appreciate people comparing Bocce The
Rock to Kion yeah and the big reason is
because I will not stand for it I am
going to go Karen mode for a second and
I will not stand for the comparison
between K on a bludgeon The Rock because
bought you the rock right as you said
there is like okay yes
let me finish I'm trolling I do a little
trolling here into that the the thing
that I really enjoyed about you the rock
as you said right is that there's like a
progression happening yeah it's like
it's like a coming-of-age story right
like a like a like a like a growth in
like character and maturity right by
using you know botchy learning to become
social through their bandmates and like
being in this like very group oriented
activity right yeah and you know that
that aspect of the story I really liked
because it's like that part of that show
was quite relatable because you know
we've all been in situations where it's
like oh I want to do something cool but
I don't have the courage to do it myself
and so you get like-minded people around
you to like push you forward right like
that's a great sentiment to have in a
story
they didn't even give a hint of that
because from episode one there was no
[__] story right the whole point of
chaon it's like watching chaon is like
watching like a bunch of exotic birds in
a cage you know it's like they'd look
really cute and pretty but you know
they're not going to do anything they're
not gonna be like oh the the birds
suddenly uh started talking and uh you
know making a revelation like what is
this you don't you don't expect when
you're looking at a cage full of exotic
birds you don't expect anything
grandiose from it but you still stand
there and watch it and enjoy yourself
that's what chaos
what is this bird analogy because I like
birds okay
it's like going to a zoo basically and
just like
Keon is like the experience of going to
a zoo and seeing your favorite animal
right you're just watching them do their
thing you don't expect
they might [__] themselves
let me cook let me cook right and so the
reason why I don't appreciate the the
comparison between Keon and Bocce is
because they went into the whole cute
girls making music thing at a completely
different angle right there wasn't
enough zoos actually I just realized
that there wasn't enough animals yeah no
there wasn't I had to bring the
australianism into it right so that's
why like you know I if if there was a
show to compare Bocce to right in the
world of anime more than chaon I would
say Beck [__] off joey yes
but these who's seen back here
okay
because both shows are about you know uh
a dude a main character or a girl in the
case with Bocce right wanting to start a
band but he doesn't have the courage to
do it himself so he gets like-minded
individuals to make that dream a reality
granted the main character of Beck isn't
as socially a nabbed as story right but
it's the same type of story right but
yeah but I would argue that Bocce is
like right in the middle of uh Kayon and
back that's that's that it was like The
Best of Both Worlds is that in terms of
enjoyability though sorry is that in
terms of enjoyability yes because
everybody knows Beck is okay yeah I feel
like my I'm like the kitten the divorced
parents like you like what what are
those Stars hey you're the one you're
the one that started this corner
yeah
I I think I can sum this up in one line
sure all right is it because she's not
like you for oil
no
the most was the drunk bass player girl
who everybody knows is the best
character in bocce everyone knows she's
the best she's the best all right all
right I agree I agree yeah finally
something we can agree on yes when
you're talking then it just reminded me
of the you know the um the Emoji that's
just the nerd yeah I don't know I don't
know why I wasn't trying to be mean
[Laughter]
but other than that yeah um yeah have we
all seen have we all seen oceanico
yeah you've you've even seen that right
corner I have what did you think about
it it was good
but it was weird
explain weird how well okay so first of
all I can't spoil live because I can't
just have you delete your ears in the
episode we can just be like spoiler
warning please leave so I won't spoil
okay unless you want me to I'm getting
that way but I could and you couldn't do
anything about it
and you can't leave
I won't though I won't
I won't
okay okay I'll stop it's it it feels
it's really weird because it just seems
like I was watching it I was like huh
this is just like YouTubers
with all the secrets and okay it's like
it's like everything seemed like online
stuff too it was really weird yeah yeah
I think that's intense I think that's
what's so good about oceanico it's kind
of like I think I think I described it
as like Black Mirror but for the
Japanese everything's Black Mirror okay
okay okay it is so it is it's like it's
just a more depressing look and I
honestly a more honest look at you know
how the idol industry is everyone knows
sucks
yeah but the good thing about oceanico
is that like uh later down the line they
go into so much more than that I hope
yeah and it's like of every corner of
the entertainment industry which is like
the more you read the Manga you're just
like oh man this this is too real I have
to like close this especially as a
YouTuber I'm just like oh my God I did
not it's like when you accidentally like
stumble upon a hate comment and it just
ruins your day you know it's just like I
didn't I didn't need to see that right
now I I knew it was there I just didn't
want to see it it has one of the most
like insane premises to explain to
someone against that you sound insane if
you say you like this show and then
you're like oh my the way uh it's about
a dude who was in love with a girl and
then Becomes Her Child so
bro you just spoiled it that's not a
spoiler that's the first [__] 10
minutes
yeah so did you go into it blind I'm
curious no because remember we did the
string where we kind of talked about it
uh the manga did we talk yes we did we
got paid too
we got paid to talk about the anime
rankings oh sorry the manga ranks oh oh
yes and then when you told me about the
show I was like what the [__]
it's just dude there's so much weird
anime there's so much stuff that's so
it's like you you know we've gotten to
the point that we've gone too far when
that's one of the more tame things this
season like God was telling me about
this anime about a dude who gets
reincarnated as a girl's dog
yeah we uh we don't talk about that have
you guys seen this
don't what are you excited about why
were you clapping why
I saw one person clapping yeah I
couldn't it's anime like that where I'm
like oh that's why I stopped watching
yeah this is this is where anime has
gone too far okay it doesn't sound that
bad when you say that but then when you
find out what happens in the show you're
like oh God oh God we should have we
should have stopped it's the whole POV
man if they did make a POV it just would
have been it's POV it's POV yeah it's
POV yeah if it wasn't POV it I mean it
still would have been weird but it
wouldn't have been as weird you know POV
just makes everything creepier
because the only things that are shot at
POV are Pawn
sure that is true that's the only place
we actually see POV and we like it right
oh my God yeah and then uh and then the
other show I watched was uh hell's
Paradise Health Paradise oh my God like
again this is another one like oceanico
I had read uh like did you read the
Manga for that because okay I'm only
watching the anime and like what I'm
getting from hell's Paradise is
everything that I I'm never gonna get
from Hunters uh Hunter Hunters Dark
Continent Arc
yeah yeah yeah because anyone caught up
on Hunter Hunter to the point where it
is because it's never going to continue
yeah trick question it's never
continuing okay like full review wow
yeah no what I think what I liked about
uh hell's Paradise is that even though
it's a Shonen Jump manga it just feels
like it's gone back to like the early
2000s like just like we don't give a
[__] anymore just like let's just make
it the most gory messed up show but also
make it like just I don't know really
cool and entertaining and it's like like
the monster designs in Hell's Paradise
are like legitimate nightmare fuel like
it's terrifying it's like it's like some
like Bleach hollow [__] you know like
yeah been meaning to watch it but I
wanted to wait for more episodes to come
out yeah it feels like the kind of show
that I want to watch like all of it and
one yeah I really regret starting it now
because I have to wait late every week
now dude this is like I've been watching
Finland Saga if you haven't watched it
you should watch it oh hell yeah oh yeah
hell yeah and it's amazing but watching
people play Farmville week by week is so
slow yeah that's why I'm waiting for it
to just finish I'm an idiot I should
have waited longer yeah yeah because I
think the manga's on the final Arc right
now yeah yeah it's funny because when
villain Saga season 2 started airing I
thought a lot of people were gonna drop
it because there was a very very
different from season one yeah very slow
about a totally different thing now the
violence is gone uh but generally people
don't seem to be complaining I don't
know I think I think it's because like
they've just heard through the great
find where it's like just just live just
get past this part and it'll be worth it
I think Australia would like it because
it's about the English getting [__] as
well so I think like it's good that's
for sure that's true I see it we should
we should take this Advantage I'm just
realizing now yeah you know because we
have a live studio audience and
sometimes we do these shows and people
always like why didn't they talk about
that anime so if you guys make some
noise for which anime you want us to
talk about we'll talk about it just go
crazy start shouting things foreign
[Applause]
I can only hear JoJo okay do it again do
it again
[__] I just saw JoJo again
that one JoJo fan so goddamn loud how
could you shout so loud with a dick in
your mouth huh
so we want to talk about
It's [__] amazing what is there to
talk about yeah the only thing we we're
going to say about JoJo is that uh all
of you should be watching it doesn't
matter what kind of anime you're into
you should give it a go did you do
anything else uh did I did I hear oh
someone said oh
you will strike on as well I watched
Trigon Stampede oh it's so good it's so
good [__] amazing yeah so I mean it's
trying on like I and it's Studio orange
and I'm like yeah match made in heaven
uh yeah so I came in to try gun uh
obviously not remembering much of the
original series that aired like I feel
like a decade or two ago right now yeah
so I didn't remember much and I feel
like that only helped my experience with
Trigun Stampede because not only does it
take kind of a different direction to
the original Trigon yeah it also does
things that the Trigun the original
Trigun never covered as well yeah yeah
yeah and uh all I can say is it's
[__] incredible Studio orange somehow
has uh knocked it out of the parking
yeah I don't know like I thought they
would like achieved peak in B stars and
then they were just like hold my beer
with a Trigon because oh my God it's
like
it's just that last episode especially
I've obviously not going to spoil it but
oh my God that lot there's a loss
there's a scene in the last episode
where Studio orange just flexed the [__]
out with their animation and it looks
insane yeah so please give it a watch
like would you say would you say you can
watch Trigon Stampede without
necessarily watching the original oh you
don't need to watch the original show in
fact I think it might be better if you
don't watch the original show uh because
it's two totally different Vibes yeah
right did you get that as well yeah no
absolutely like I feel the the original
Trigon was very much like you know the
the Western you know the spaghetti
western aesthetic that you know it was
was present in it and then with like
hints of sci-fi whereas Trigon Stampede
is just full-on sci-fi like right
there's like a little bit of the kind of
spaghetti western feel to it but it's
just like they they did the uh they did
the trigger effect basically they were
like we're going to space
laughs
[Applause]
not the original Trigon
okay all right Edition man okay so even
if you didn't put your hands up please
give Trigon stamped a good you don't
have to watch the original it is insane
insanely good it got me to watch it
I don't know if I just imagined this but
I imagine it's popular enough that
someone said it did I hear Attack on
Titan as well
and I never heard about it what's that
that's the that's the quietest anyone's
ever been for attack yeah whenever we
say Attack on Titan in the states you'd
think that like you just got a new
president they were just like
yeah I think just Americans they just
shout when they know something they're
like I know that show yes
uh yeah that's good
what'd you think Joey my favorite part
about attacker Titan is uh having to
wait 500 years for anything yeah I can't
wait for that finally ending now we only
have to wait a few more months
[Applause]
and then they're going to bring out two
movies and a [__] OVA or something I
don't know that's they're gonna milk the
[__] out of it for sure it's taken 10
years
has it wait Has It wait yeah it has been
10 years hasn't it yeah yeah yeah I mean
okay
how big do you think the ending is going
to be for Attack on Titan do you think
like how much is it going to blow up the
internet I feel is it just me or
you don't hear as much about Attack on
Titan anymore as like the first couple
of Seasons because of the whole problem
of them like milking it out but also
just them taking way too goddamn long to
like get to the point you know so like I
don't know if they've like shot
themselves in the foot in that regard of
go like I don't know like is it just me
like you don't there's obviously people
talking about Attack on Titan right but
I don't feel it's nearly near the peak
that it was during like season one for
instance right uh I would still think
it's still super [__] popular oh it's
still super popular more popular than
like any anime I would argue and not any
anime but it's definitely like up there
like I think after like the top two like
seasonal anime it's like it's there in
like the top five at least but like I
don't know I remember when like season
one came out oh my God like my grandma
knew what the [__] Attack on Titan was
like that that [__] was everywhere
especially how did your grandma know
about it because my oh my Japanese
Grandma's like she's actually quiet she
loves demon slam what yeah your base
grandma Yeah my best grandma my grandma
my uncle my aunt they're like all fans
of demons my dad's still trying to
figure out what anime is like he's like
I've watched 10 I don't even know what
it is
all right Joey real questions you know
what's airing next season
yes are you gonna be watching to Jessica
ice in season two Joey you know what I
actually will
are you actually yeah are you actually
but he called it mid yeah I still finish
season one though
I'm going to watch season two so that I
can further confirm how mid it is no
can we get a boo can we get a boo for
that
thank you
I don't know if you ever explained why
you think it's just mid or you're just
like
do you have a natural reason like I
think for me it's it's completely like
like unprecedented like my reasoning
behind it like how I feel
that's right I've never had someone
refer to their own opinions as
unprecedented this is an unprecedented
it's unprecedented because like okay my
the the how I feel about Jesus Christ
and right is how I felt about
um what's the one uh with uh senku the
main character
Dr Stone
that's how I felt watching Dr Stone is
how I felt into this guy soon in the
sense that I I looked at the synopsis
for both shows right and like the
background of it all and it ticked off
all of the boxes of what I like in an
anime right and so I was like well
obviously this is going to be a great
[__] show I'm going to enjoy the [__]
out of it right and then you start
watching it and it's just this feeling
of like
this is not quite what I wanted and it's
really difficult to explain it's it's
like literally A vibe check like I'm I'm
Vibe checking Dr Stone and Jesus Christ
and I've been like
I know this has all the things I love in
it but some combination of this I don't
know where it is or what it is it just
doesn't feel like the show that I was
hoping it was going to be you know like
I got the same thing with Carolyn
Tuesday
okay when I watched Carol on Tuesday I
was like okay it's what's on our machine
churro amazing writer it's about music
it's you know it's it's sci-fi it's like
this is everything I [__] love in an
anime and I watched and I'm like
it it was good but like something's
missing and I don't know what it is do
you get that feeling I I actually no I
agree with you yeah I had such high
expectations with Carolyn Tuesday Yeah
just something about it just didn't hit
the story beats I wanted exactly well I
do want to re-watch it because uh I
remember Carolyn Tuesday and this
synopsis or the premise of Carolyn
Tuesday is actually
scarily accurate to what's going on now
so if you don't know if you haven't seen
Caroline Tuesday uh it's a exploration
about
real music and musicians versus music
that is AI generated
very topical today it is it is very very
topical today because uh let's be honest
we're gonna replace we're going to be
replaced by AI in like five years right
we've all heard that Drake and weekend
AI song right yeah
that [__] slapped yeah yeah like I think
my favorite meme right now is the Harry
Potter like not the Harry Potter the
Balenciaga AI memes that was Harry
Potter no no because because they've
done collaborations with like Harry
Potter and like all these like movie
franchises of like all these movie
characters basically AI generated into
like Shilling out for Balenciaga it's
the weirdest thing to pick it up when
you get up and then there's the recent
presidential like debate Oh no just like
the president AI generated conversations
like OverWatch and stuff like that yeah
they like playing Minecraft and [__]
yeah yeah
no I I agree like and so like how I felt
about like Carolyn Tuesday and like Dr
Stone it's basically how I felt about
Jesus guys like right in the sense that
it's like I I actually hate the fact
that I think it's mid because I it was
everything that I wanted in again no I
do and it's like I hate the fact that I
think that because it's like again it
was everything that I thought I wanted
in a new Shonen and just something about
it didn't click with me and I don't know
why and that's why I hate trying to
explain why I Think Jesus Christ said
it's me it because I know it's just a me
problem it's just a me it's just a yes
it is literally
and I totally understand why people love
the [__] out of it because I wish I was
there I wish I love the [__] out of two
but I can't I swear to God Joe I I know
for a fact now if you ever get to
watching Arcane you're gonna think it's
mad yeah I swear to God Joey I'm not
you know maybe I'm doing a service by
not watching it no he should watch out
no he should he watch our game
okay but all I'm saying is don't yell
and Shout at me when I come back and say
Arcane is mid all right you forced me to
watch it boom
thanks guys
and you guys will do anything
is so much better when I can command
people to move yeah I can just be like I
don't like that opinion boo guys
this is what Connor gets when he has a
live twitch audience in front of him
yeah you've given him too much power way
too much power
but uh yeah but uh I think we have just
about run out of time for this trash
taste recording uh wait uh Before We Say
Goodbye Joey you gotta you got to do the
thing Joey do the thing oh yeah guys
watching at home look at all these
patrons on the screen oh
seal
audience look at all the pages
what do you think of this member
[Applause]
[Music]
not enough of you and I'll tell you what
you know where you can be a patron by
going to patreon.com trash taste links
in the description also follow us on
Twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if I hate our face listen
to us on Spotify and thank you dreamhack
Melbourne for making this an awesome
episode give yourself a round of
applause
thank you guys this is fun we need to do
more of these this is fun uh this was
also nerve-wracking because this is the
first trash days episode we've filmed in
front of an audience uh and it's the
first time I've never taken a piss break
mid recording so
[Applause]
yes congratulations
real reason we're ending it I really
really need to piss like right now
normally we can pause the recording
we're like all right let's go for a
press bake and come back but uh thank
you very much guy uh thank you very much
for attending guys
and for all of you watching at home
we'll see you all next week
[Music]